live by night this takes us a period
piece it takes place in Tampa in the
1920s and I think we have still here
from the movie of you with a Ben Affleck
and you get to wear the clothes from
that era and I was curious did you did
you like wearing those clothes or did
you really not like wearing those
clothes I did I loved the costume
designer it like oh it was so much in
the details and everything so all the
clothes were like authentically from the
1920s and like the socks and the
underwear like everything was from the
1920 no one's seeing the underwear who
cares what underwear you wear I think
but it just it mattered obviously no
one's seeing it but it just I don't know
the way that you like watch everything
you could smell that it was like not
like I know exactly what you're talking
about I have a private collection of old
underwear the same thing such a weird
thing yeah no I I would say I think the
women look very cool than cool clothes I
love that the 1920s kind of clothes
yeah and hats hat when I put that stuff
on I look like a kid that would sell you
an apple ooh the Depression you know I
just have that kind of face of like you
know and so I love those kind of clothes
and I actually feel like I'd become more
like that sort of person yeah when you
walk a certain way and yes
[Laughter]
you
you